okay I told you last week that the
retirement of Supreme Court Justice
Anthony Kennedy stunk
everything about it stunk it didn't
sound right we knew about the
connections between Donald Trump and
Anthony Kennedy's son at Deutsche Bank
Justin Kennedy the timing was odd it was
something that reportedly came as a sort
of surprise to the other justices the
other justices are usually sort of
notified in advance when a Supreme Court
justice plans to retired and now not
only do we have news that a deal was
made for Kennedy's retirement the White
House isn't even denying it and this is
quickly becoming one of the biggest
stories of cronyism and corruption and
strong-arming involving the Trump
administration and the Supreme Court and
that says a lot because we've seen a lot
of cronyism and corruption and
strong-arming that this administration
has been involved that here is what we
know we've learned that the Trump
administration was negotiating the
retirement of Justice Anthony Kennedy
with Anthony Kennedy and they ultimately
assured Kennedy in advance that if he
retired they would replace him with
Brett Kavanaugh whose nomination we
learned about on Monday night and as the
story goes during the negotiations but
took place took place in 2017 Anthony
Kennedy gave Trump a list of people who
he would be ok with as a replacement
and this reportedly goes all the way
back to late 2017 I said yesterday that
Cavanaugh wasn't on the original list
remember originally Trump said I'm gonna
pick justices from this list and it was
like a Heritage Foundation or some
right-wing think tank list Cavanaugh
wasn't on that list originally but he
was added to the list in November with
four other names what we've now learned
according to the reporting that that has
surfaced in the last 24 hours is that
back in November when Brett Cavanaugh
was added to the list along with four
other names it had already been
negotiated that Cavanaugh would be the
replacement to Anthony Kennedy but that
it would be too suspicious if you only
say remember that list from two years
ago or from a year ago I'm gonna just
add one name to that list don't worry
about it has nothing to do with anything
we're involved in that would be too
suspicious
four additional names were added as
deliberate red herrings to cover up that
Cavanaugh was already the guy who was
being negotiated to replace Justice
Anthony Kennedy at that time we are
seeing a total subjugation of checks and
balances were seeing the circumvention
of the independence of branches of
government and what's the wackiest of
all is that the White House isn't
denying it yesterday deputy press
secretary Raj Shah who is only surpassed
in his vile and depraved nature by his
number one in command Sara Huckabee
Sanders the actual press secretary Raj
Shah said yesterday some assurances have
been made and not denying anything about
this story take a look in the selection
process did President Trump speak to
outgoing Justice Anthony Kennedy at all
about Judge Cavanaugh prior to the
nomination so the President did speak
with Justice Kennedy yesterday to inform
him of his choice prior to that John
yeah let me answer and he met with
Justice Kennedy at the White House on
the Wednesday of the week before last
when Justice Kennedy made his
announcement so the president has talked
to Justice Kennedy but this was the
president's choice understand that Judge
Cavanaugh was on his publicly disclosed
list as far back as last November right
he was on the list since last November
because he was added along with four
other names as political cover and it
had already been negotiated this
continues with Raja the Justice Kennedy
expressed his support for judge
Cavanaugh prior to the nomination last
week well I'll allow Justice Kennedy to
speak for himself
obviously judge Cavanaugh did clerk for
him in the Supreme Court so did a few
others that's what we call a yes in
political press secretary speak and we
have yet another instance of a
non-denial here there are reports this
morning that as far back as months ago
that Brett Kavanaugh was used Justice
Kennedy
basically made clear that he would like
to see judge Cavanaugh as his
replacement did anyone inside the white
house they're connected to the white
house speak to Anthony Kennedy about
judge Cavanaugh dating back months well
again I'm not gonna read out private
conversations that Justice Kennedy had
with either members of the White House
or the president ding that's another yes
this went on for six minutes no denials
because it's all true it's all true
Justice Anthony Kennedy has given
control of a seat
has has had control of a seat not only
for his time on the court but for
whatever number of years Brett Kavanaugh
ends up being on the court and soon the
story will change too it's not illegal
anyway so who cares and of course it
doesn't matter even if it were illegal
the Democrats deserved it because of
either Hillary's emails or uranium one
or some such nonsense that come up with
Supreme Court justices are supposed to
have more integrity than this and
there's a lot here that stinks be it
that Cavanaugh clerked for Kennedy or
you know the very specifics of this deal
like the fact that Cavanaugh's son I had
some shady business dealings with Donald
Trump at one point any son of home he's
not having us on we're not breaking any
news here I just to 2k names there step
back for a second and ask yourself what
if Obama had done this what if it had
been revealed that Obama was given a
name a list of names of replacements to
pick from by the retiring justice and he
did it six months prior to the
retirement or eight months prior to the
retirement and that the name was added
surreptitiously with four other
deliberate red herrings to a list to
cover the fact that the replacement had
already been selected forget about that
what if Obama had pre announced he'd be
picking from a list at all when the list
came from a think tank it would be a
very very different situation and
right-wing media would be absolutely
losing their minds and what this gets us
to you know where it gets us to vote
this November send me your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I'm pleased
to tell you that today's show is
underwritten by better help.com slash
Pakman therapy is important we have a
real crisis in our country not just
people who could benefit from mental
services but the stigma that surrounds
mental health services and as many
people in the audience know lots of
people in my family work in the field of
mental health and I have made it a
mission of the show to it any
opportunity make clear that there is
absolutely no shame whatsoever in going
to talk to someone when you feel that
that's the right thing to do and that's
what better help provides you get a
fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
videophone and text it's less expensive
than meeting in person with a counselor
after three months the price goes down
even more but you get the same
professional service that you would from
going into somebody's office and you
also get unlimited access you can speak
to a counselor every day if you want
signing up is easy you go to better help
calm slash Pakman fill out a
questionnaire they will pair you with a
therapist that works for you but you're
always able to switch to somebody else
if there's a better fit available go to
better help calm slash Pakman it's so
easy to sign up and get started we're
putting a link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube it is
better help calm a /pa que ma n